.
JESSE WATTERS, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT INSIGHT.
SO JEFF BEZOS IS NOT HAVING A
MIDLIFE CRISIS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
HE JUST BUILT A ROCKET AND TOOK
IT INTO OUTER SPACE TODAY.
JEFF BEZOS, THE FOUNDER OF
AMAZON BOARDED IT AND WAS
OUTSIDE OF OUR ATMOSPHERE FOR 1S
BROTHER MARK BASALS AS WELL AS
AN 18-YEAR-OLD STUDENT AND AN
ANOTHER --
>> DAD, WHAT'S THAT CUSTOMER >>
I DON'T KNOW, SON.
>> Tucker: YEP, THE WORLD'S
LARGEST PLANT.
WE DIDN'T MAKE THAT UP.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO PUT THAT ON
TELEVISION THAT THAT IS THE
MAN'S RICHEST MAN AND WE HAD NO
CHOICE TO COVER HIS HOBBY.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU THE NAME
OF THE ACTUAL ROCKET.
HE'S CALLING IT --
HERE IS WHAT WE ARE WANT TO TELL
YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO TELL YOU ABOUT
HIS RECEPTION.
AS SOON AS HE LANDED, HE WAS
GREETED BY A THRONG OF HIS OWN
REPORTERS, HE OWNS
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
YOU TEND TO GET GOOD COVERAGE
WHEN YOU PAY THE PEOPLE
PRODUCING IT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW
BAD LIFE CAN BE.
THEY COULD BE WORKING AT AN
AMAZON FULFILLMENT CENTER IN
CANS FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIFE.
THEY IMMEDIATELY ASKED HIM FOR
COMMENT IN A VERY RESPECTFUL
WAY.
HOW DID HE RESPOND?
HERE'S HIS QUOTE.
BEST DAY EVER.
THAT WAS IT.
NOT ONE SMALL STEP FOR MAN OR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TIME FOR
RHETORICAL FLOURISHES.
HE SELLS BOOKS.
HE DOESN'T WRITE THEM.
BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER.
OUR MEDIA WERE IMPRESSED.
THEY BOWED BEFORE THE RICHEST
MAN.
BEST DAY EVER, HIS THREE
SYLLABLES, BUT THREE SYLLABLES
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND VERY WELL.
THE HEAVILY COIFFED TV ANCHORS
WHO SPEND THEIR DAY IN HAIR AND
MAKEUP.
THE COMMENTERS ON TELEVISION
WERE UNANIMOUS.
THIS WAS BETTER THAN ANYTHING
JOHN GLENN EVER DID.
>> TODAY WAS A BIG DAY.
EXACTLY 52 YEARS SINCE THE FIRST
MOON LANDING.
ANOTHER LANDMARK MOMENT IN
SPACEX FORMATION.
HERE YOU SEE BILLIONAIRE AMAZON
FOUNDER.
THEY REACHED THE EDGE OF SPACE
AND FLOATED ZERO GRAVITY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY I AM, WHEN I
WAS --
WE STOPPED AND WATCHED THE
ORIGINAL GLENN LAUNCH.
I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE THAT.
I THINK THAT AMERICA WANTS TO
KNOW ABOUT THIS VERY MUCH.
I DON'T BLAME US.
BECAUSE I THINK IS THE MOST,
THIS IS ONE OF THE GREAT
BUSINESS STORIES OF ALL TIME
BECAUSE IT IS PRIVATE EQUITY,
PRIVATE ENTERPRISE.
>> AND IT REALLY IS OBVIOUSLY A
BIG STEP FOR FUTURE SPACE
TOURISM.
BUT IT'S A REMARKABLE STEP IN A
MISSION THAT BEGAN MORE THAN TWO
DECADES AGO WHEN HE FOUNDED
BLUEORGIN.
>> DETERMINED TO ADVANCE SPACE
TRAVEL.
I WANT TO KNOW, WHAT DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE LIKE TO BE UP THERE
TOGETHER WHEN YOU LOCKED EYES?
>> Tucker: HOUSTON, WE ARE
LEAVING THE ATMOSPHERE.
[LAUGHS]
I'M SO IMPRESSED.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
SLOBBERING OVER JEFF BEZOS.
AND WHY DO YOU LOVE JEFF BEZOS
SO MUCH?
WELL, WE JUST FOUND OUT TODAY
JEFF BEZOS IS GIVING
$100 MILLION, NO STRINGS
ATTACHED TO CNN CONTRIBUTOR.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TAKEN BY A
LOT OF LOVE.
THEY LOVE HIM AT CNN.
THEY LOVE HIM.
JEFF BEZOS.
HOW DO YOU TREAT YOUR EMPLOYEES,
JEFF BEZOS?
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
HOW EXACTLY DO YOU OWN THE
CAPITAL CITY'S LOCAL NEWSPAPER?
NO ONE ASKED THOSE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE IN THE END COME EVERYONE
IS HOPING TO GET MONEY FROM
JEFF BEZOS.
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T GETTING MONEY
FROM JEFF BEZOS HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT VIEW OF HIM.
HERE'S TULSI GABBARD'S.
NOT TAKING MONEY FROM HIM.
THE ONLY PROBLEM I HAVE WITH HIS
ROCKET SHIP INTO OUTER SPACE IS
THAT IT'S GOING T